[Music]
foreign I actually had to implement some
advice that you gave me today this week
wait you gave me some advice that like
changed my life wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait what
what Diablo Cody's here what
uh are we
yeah wages are all okay
I was gonna say that remember when you
said this is super professional no I
love this that's where it is this is
where it ends no a few years ago I had
to in fact it was probably like seven or
eight years now I had to call you
because my brother had overdosed and you
helped me get him into a rehab center
because I wanted to date him I don't I
actually don't think that was what was
happening
um and unfortunately uh I don't think
the center fixed him completely
um but it was uh they can't no no you
know I know I was just being physician
yes but it was uh very I was for 80
grand a month you'd think you would
think so right I think they could fix me
I just have to give them a chance maybe
one day yeah thank you guys for keeping
me poor which keeps me motivated to work
harder I do think paying for rehabs is
part of the reason I'm so ambitious I
just like have to get cash quick yeah I
have you know done my share of paying
for rehabs as well and so you and I
bonded over that and um but one piece of
advice you gave me which is you know
this is like deeply personal shit but
um stop being so annoying and he'll stop
drinking so much no it wasn't it it was
actually about my mom because my mom was
and remains in denial about my brother's
issues and I told you about my mom's
history and how she had been raised by
an alcohol and you said to me you will
never be able to change that she has
built up such a wall of protection
around herself because of her childhood
and it is permanent and you cannot
expect her to start knocking it down now
and seeing things for what they are and
it's advice that I have implemented
probably a hundred times since we had
that conversation that's how we love
them more is we just forgive them for
things that were out of their control
it's like we forgive others not because
they deserve forgiveness because we
deserve peace but it's like you know the
idea of a woman who grew up in the
the 40s 50s 40s and 50s having any
concept that alcohol is bad yeah I just
have so much radical love and
forgiveness for our parents yeah because
I actually think they did better than
they should have given the tools they
lacked I think about this all the time
and I also you know I spent so many
years
wondering why you know I wasn't more
seen as a child or why I wasn't nurtured
in a certain way or you know my you know
you know what I'm talking about like
basically the way you know parents today
just seem so much more aware and so much
more evolved but when I look back on it
I think to myself my God it was the 70s
it was the 80s they had neither of them
had ever been to therapy like they were
all high on Aquanet they were high on
Aqua Net so was I and they were working
their asses off they didn't have time to
sit around and talk to me about my
religious trauma they were like just
keep her alive yeah
I have to make her lunch I have to get
her ready for cheerleading at 6 PM that
the last thing they were thinking about
was like you know my my stupid because
their dads worked in factories at 14
right so they're like she's fine she's
in on a couch watching TV we're spoiling
her oh exactly they were like this is
the perfect childhood and then also like
it's just sort of like I look back I
know this is half a joke but it's like
when I think about like why didn't my
dad talk to why do you spend more time
with me when I was like five and talk to
me what the fuck did I have to say it's
like why I'd rather my dad not have
talked to me than found out how boring I
was I mean this is kind of an asshole
thing to say as a mom of three but I the
world has gotten way too child-centered
when I tell you it's like I I'm I'm
doing this joke about like I always have
to say something's a joke because I just
I get too embarrassed and ashamed but um
about this new gay Panic where parents
are obsessed with like the drag queens
or molesting our kids and the trans
people are molesting our kids it's like
all your your obsession with your child
getting molest all you're doing is
saying that you think your kid is hot
like you think your kid is like worth
going to jail for like if you because
they're like my kid was in a public
bathroom with a drag queen for two
minutes it's like that's not enough time
like I mean I I I love where you're
going with this you where you think it's
like parental hubris like oh you think
your kid has what it takes yep exactly
right and also like you think someone
looks at your kid is like you know what
I'll just end my life just to touch that
for 30 seconds it's just like yes
there's people that are mentally ill but
it also was like I was molested by a
straight guy and that is dramatic yeah
people are all molested if I was
molested by a drag queen I feel like I
would have had the confidence like I
wanted so much earlier because at least
there would have been a um triumphant
Anthem playing in the background so I
could overcome the adversity I was
currently experiencing you think I just
would have had like the first time
putting a queer lens on it makes it a
little more powerful at least the
background music would have been you
know like you're a firework I'd be like
I am like at least so anyway agree and I
would love to talk about that um because
I think a lot of the themes in the
Jagged Little film musical watching that
Mom
obsess over having to deal with the pr
it's also I see so many moms that are
struggling with drug problems and
painkiller problems and edible problems
because of the pressure of being the
perfect parent and I think the best
thing you can do for a child is have
flaws and acknowledge them and show that
you can have flaws and still succeed you
can have flaws and still course correct
you can apologize if you did something
wrong like
yeah I have learned that that actually
has been a very valuable lesson for me
because having flaws was not modeled for
me you know I had obviously my parents
are flawed people but they were very um
stiff upper lip Midwestern like did not
cry in front of me ever I mean it was
you know it was 10 degrees Yeah I mean
of course they did see me cry on like a
daily basis like I'm like a complete
vulnerable Real mess in front of them so
and it's boys like that what's better
than that I mean I hope it's good for
them either that or they're gonna be
like yeah we were raised by like an
insane narcissist no you know by the way
I just I think that like
a couple things number one I the older I
get the more I am obsessed with
ancestral trauma the stuff that has
nothing to do with nurture the stuff
that's imprinted on our genes because so
much it's like you know genetics loads
the gut environment pulls the trigger
like it's like nothing personal to
parents but like it's not it's not all
to your credit and it's not all your
fault there's a lot of pre-loaded
software that's I talk to people about
this all the time because I really the
one thing and not to keep coming back to
having three children like it's my
entire personality but one thing about
having three is you realize how much of
it is preloaded software because you can
raise three kids in the exact same
household with the exact same rules you
know everything and they're three
completely different human beings with
different you know moral compasses
different everything and there's so much
um sort of uh uh literature now on
because my thing was like my parents
were kind of never around so there was
like a little bit of an absence so like
what was the other siblings also have
almost as big of an impact on you as
your parents oh I believe that one which
is so crazy yeah because a lot of times
like we're looking up to our older
sibling and then they end up being our
babysitter at some point you know that's
whose approval I really wanted my older
sisters approval way more than my dad or
my mom the same is true for me I
wouldn't be sitting in this podcast
right now talking to you if I had been
an only child like having an older
brother who was such a looming figure in
my life completely informed to the
person that I am we don't spend enough
time with like birth order and sort of
like what we developed and the
self-limiting beliefs or
self-aggrandizing beliefs whatever that
we got from our siblings you know or
having to be an older sibling and having
to caretake a younger sibling too early
you know like I'm the youngest and I
know a lot of people that are the
youngest in this business because I
think that we're same perfectly
qualified because we learned a shape
shift we learned to fit into an already
existing system and like you know we a
lot of us were mistakes and that's fine
mine too or as we my mom says a surprise
you know and I think that um uh uh can I
ask uh sometimes I cut myself off when I
get bored of what I'm saying
um and feel like I'm talking too much
but can you connect anything to the
things that you used to think were a
disadvantage in your childhood or from
your primary caretakers that now you see
as like a superpower that you're like
absolutely I'm so embarrassed for all
the people that had all that love
yeah well there's that but for me the
big thing is my family was not while
they weren't dismissive they were not
particularly encouraging of my creative
Pursuits like it was just like oh Brooke
wants to be a writer but no one writes
for a living so she'll be an English
teacher and I mean that was what my
parents always said to people it would
just by the way nothing wrong with being
an English teacher but I was told that I
could not you know support myself solely
as a as a writer
and meanwhile when I grew up and came to
La I met so many people who had just
been like completely nurtured as artists
by their families like sent to the fancy
camp in Michigan where you're with you
know like all the stuff like the you
know internships and oh my mom is a
sculptor and but you know she taught me
you know stuff like that that I couldn't
even begin to relate to yeah you know
what's going really well right now is uh
statues I'm just Americans really like
keeping those up just cool people grew
up in these cool artistic environments
with parents who totally you know groked
what they were trying to do and I
honestly think that that would have put
me at a disadvantage I think it would
have made me very sort of
complacent it like it being dismissed
lit a fire under me that was essential
and you know something my dad used to
always say to me that I'm I don't
encourage people say to their parents I
don't know enough about parenting to be
able to even give advice do what you do
it's none of my business
um I'm not the per I literally have
friends that have kids and we'll go out
in public with the kids and some
stranger like someone will just walk
with some woman to walk and be like you
better put sunscreen on that kid oh that
happens all the time what are you doing
like actually you just did that in front
of your kid
yeah I mean older women are specifically
crazy about socks like if you bring a
baby out without socks like 15 women
over the age of 65 will descend on your
baby and be like his feet are cold wear
his socks wear his socks and it's like
it's 90 degrees
ma'am I'm sorry you have a foot fetish I
don't know I was like why are you
looking at my baby's feet I know exactly
why did you even see this why did you
notice why do you need them to be
covered up so bad because yeah pussy's
getting wet it's just so wild to me oh
my God
welcome to the show yes um uh so that is
fascinating because yeah I look around a
lot of people um around me constantly
feeling like they deserve more that I
should be getting even uh there's an
epidemic right now uh of what I call
sore winners who it's like you know I
didn't get it the way I wanted it and I
was told my dad was very clear a lot of
therapists have told me this was like
not a good thing for him to have done I
disagree
um which is he would always say life is
not fair he goes you will always have to
work twice as hard to get half as far
and like I would come home and be like I
gotta be on this test but I shouldn't
have because they didn't they were
supposed to give it Friday and they gave
it today and he's like that's always how
it's gonna you have to be ready for
things to never be on your terms you
have to be so good that you have to be
able to do it with a headache you have
to be able to do it with no sleep you
have to be able to do it with a
boyfriend that just broke up with you
distracted and he would wake me up in
the middle of the night and quiz me on
spelling words in the middle of the
night
at the time and we would literally I
would scream and cry because he would
not let me watch Beverly Hills 90210
until I got every spelling word forward
and backwards and ever and he would quiz
me on chapters that were not in the test
because he was just like you're gonna
have to
they're gonna try to throw you for a
loop and I'm not gonna let anyone ever
trick you well do you feel that that was
advantageous or do you look back and say
to this I look back I'm like I have this
wild advantage of like people talk about
my work ethic and I'm like it doesn't
occur to me that I work hard like I saw
my mom worked you know I went to uh
department stores after school and
watched her work like she was busy as
shit and never like around and then my
dad made me work my ass off and so it's
like I think I just have a higher
tolerance for a different definition of
like hard than other people do I like
that it like I I feel really grateful
because I see a lot of people around me
that are winning and they're miserable
or they feel they're entitled to work
less and get more I know exactly what
you mean by the store winners I like
that term I'm stealing it it's so good
there are a lot of them a lot of them
there's I mean an entitlement issue in
general in this industry you know like
it's just I really
want to be on track with you because I'm
so excited about this and I am like I've
known you for a while yeah a long time a
really long time and I feel like we
haven't gotten to spend a lot of time
together but I'm gonna try to keep
because I have so many professional
questions for you let's do it and I will
get eaten alive uh by the fans if I
don't so okay can I ask you some
questions about Alanis Morissette
absolutely and this uh so my deal with
podcasting is I don't ask any questions
that have already been asked of you on
other podcasts so her on Chris Hardwick
is incredible her on the box is
incredible I don't want to ask any
questions you've already been asked
because I hate it when I hate it when
people uh ask you like so how did you
get into writing and you're like this is
somewhere
this is somewhere this can be yeah it's
somewhere so all the ques those
questions it's all those spoiler alert
that's been on the internet for 10 years
go find it may I just ask you when you
first heard uh the Alanis Morissette
album where were you what was going on
when you ought to know came out where
were you in your life what happened you
know what's so crazy is I have such a a
clear core memory of this and I it's
it's funny because it's I don't know
it's just odd to me because you don't
usually remember the exactly where you
were the first time you heard a popular
song you just remember if you liked it
or not but I specifically remember
sitting in my bedroom in the Chicago
suburbs and I was listening to q101
which is Chicago's Rock alternative
and the DJ did something that they
rarely did in like corporate radio and
he came on and he said I'm about to play
a song that is so amazing that like
nobody here can stop talking about it
like he like usually you know what they
don't do that on like a mainstream radio
station but he was editorializing he was
like no this is going to be great like
get ready buckle up and you ought to
know it started playing and sure enough
I remember sitting there like you know I
of course when you're 15 or 16 you think
you're like the greatest judge of
everything yeah I'm like I'm sitting
there like let's see if this is any good
you know like hmm I don't know like I
would have mixed the drums a little
lower or whatever so um
but I was listening to it I was like oh
yeah like this is definitely like
this is a moment right and so of course
that whole summer of Jagged Little Pill
was like me and my friends cranking it
in the car like screaming along
like you're even saying The Yodeling oh
you did it all like you became her you
know it's like but yeah I think weirdly
all I want was like the single off that
album that really got to me yeah because
I just remember feeling like
nobody was listening and and I was
surrounded by sheep you know it's just
that Vibe and the crazy thing is to me
you know she was an adult having an
adult life but now I know that she was
you know 19 when she wrote two songs 20
when she recorded them maybe when the
album came out like she's a kid
like do you remember what I mean it's
been spoken about you know enough so I
don't want to rehash what's already been
said but I do for me certainly I grew up
in a ACA environment uh you know grew
into an alcoholic home eggshells
everywhere your feelings were
overwhelming to the parents having needs
was exhausting to people and there was
borderline personality in my family so
there was a lot of like can I have some
dinner well okay well why don't I just
get hit by a bus why don't I get a new
mother it was like I had a mother that
was very overwhelmed and when I had
needs I think it made her feel like she
was not doing a good enough job as a mom
and it came out you know like I felt it
like I felt like she was always at a
boiling point she was overwhelmed you
know and she as she was she had a
full-time job and kids and was going
through a horrible divorce and she was
just at capacity mentally she didn't
have you know so I remember really
having to swallow my feelings not have
any feelings be perfect always be happy
don't ask for anything you know chronic
you know which yielded chronic
self-deprivation sort of a chronic
Independence that you you know isn't
helpful too early a precociousness and I
remember when I first heard that song I
I saw it first on MTV the video first
yeah and I remember being like
women are allowed to be mad
like I I knew that we might I would see
my mom like cry when she gotta cry and
then people go this is crazy like you
can't lose your shit as a woman you're
not allowed to be upset you're not
allowed to be messy and watching her
just be like so mad
I remember going like I didn't realize
that was an option and I didn't realize
till later my goal was basically I want
to be the Alanis Morissette of Comedy
I wanted that to be messy and I want it
to be like raw and I want to make people
like uncomfortable if they're
uncomfortable that's okay too
um but I want people to be able to see
like you can be complex and angry and
emotional but also smart so emotional
doesn't mean dumb and out of control of
yourself because Atlantis was so fucking
smart she's super intellectual I mean
she is a really smart person it's wild
and then I remember
this blew my mind it was like a little
thing that I'm sure a lot of people Miss
but you know how as Catholic girls can
be so going to Catholic School same I
didn't realize that I was basically in a
stripper costume like I didn't realize
that you know Catholic school uniform is
you're a sex symbol oh completely at 10.
I didn't know what that how that read to
me you know so I got all this weird
attention from Men I'm in a Catholic
school uniform we would roll it up and
it was just like
um
I think that uniform just has to go it's
become it's too sexual it's honestly
kind of crazy that it endures because it
is like just a completely fetishized
costume it's a Halloween guy it's a hot
Halloween costume they still are like
well we insist on girls wearing the
uniforms for decency and it's like no
you're making people horny like 100 and
you and I was tall and I would go out
and men would talk to me and I was like
for you know the most sexual attention
for men that I ever got in my life was
between the ages of like 10 and 14 which
is really disturbing to look back on
I think a lot of women feel that way and
then the um you know how else Catholic
girls can be I remember being like Oh
that's sarcasm like that's sarcasm and
she's using The Stereotype that she
can't change
to her advantage
so you know how his Catholic girls can
be like we're bad so I'm gonna do bad
things so it's not my fault so it's like
you're the one putting me in this corner
and there's nothing I can do about it
but I'm gonna figure out a way to use it
to my advantage she totally turned the
tables and that's probably my favorite
song off the album well 100 well no it's
hard to choose that one definitely uh is
is
super extra powerful she owned the
stereotype yeah and was like you're
gonna think I'm this fucking bad girl
that was born bad anyway so anything I
do is bad so it's not my fault it kind
of exonerates you from the guilt that
Catholicism controls you with yeah and I
remember being like oh she just fucking
hacked the system oh yeah and I remember
the idea of going and then the rest of
my life when a guy's like you're crazy
he's like well I'm crazy so if you're
here
what's going on with you and then I
would do something and be like well I'm
crazy so yeah this is what happens
exactly you know there's a freedom in
being seen a certain way that's off or
unfair and just use it to make it fair
yesterday this lady asked me if I was
out of my mind because of the way I
parked and I said yeah
it was like yeah funny you should ask
yeah uh this is the least crazy thing
I've done today yeah Europe
it's like what everybody I mean you've
known me for so long I mean during the
pandemic I dyed my hair like a million
different colors I've been there I know
you get it yeah but it was like I never
get to do that and then once I realized
there was like we're not gonna do
anything for two years I was like oh I'm
gonna dye my hair all the colors I never
got to because doing it right is
expensive as shit it's so annoying to
keep up too like it's just I had
shampoos and all kinds of crazy stuff
and that Manic Panic were you Manic
Panic no I was using um pulp Riot nice
but it's also a lot of my friends were
losing their jobs hairdressers and stuff
and so I was like come over I'll put on
a mask we'll get tested and like do the
most expensive thing you can I was like
a pink hair blue hair and people like
Whitney's going crazy I'm like if you it
is so funny I was so much crazier when I
was a brunette like yeah me dying my
hair pink is like me doing something I
want to do and not constantly running
around with brown hair being like am I
acceptable to man am I gonna get cast in
this because my hair is right like if
I'm like it's so much saner to be like I
want pink hair I'm gonna do it and to do
it yeah I agree people always say that
about women where they're like oh if you
cut your bangs you're going through
something or it's like maybe I want
bangs maybe because I don't want to get
BOTOX I don't have time to get BOTOX I'm
just get bangs that's actually why I
have Banks and my injector gets really
angry because I get BOTOX between my
eyebrows for the angry part and because
I'm okay my whole thing is I'm okay with
looking old but I don't want to look mad
so it's just like I can be old but I
don't want to look pissed off at the
world and ironically looking old is the
only thing that makes me mad yeah I mean
it's definitely like a snake eating I
was just saying Chinese finger trap I
don't know if we can say that anymore um
and uh but I refused I don't get BOTOX
on my forehead because I have bangs and
the lady's always like but you might
grow them out because I don't know I
guess she just wants to upsell me on
more Botox and like I'm never going to
I've had them since the first grade so
in La dermatologist
worries about running out of Botox
clients you'll be fine I know I was like
yeah you're gonna be all right they're
lined up outside you'll be fine and also
like that's so wild to me because that's
what frustrates me when you're caught in
that thing and I feel like Alanis
Morissette acknowledged so much when
you're caught in that thing how do you
make it work for you when there's two
bad options yeah so the idea is like
okay so if I get BOTOX you guys are
gonna clown on me for having Botox right
and me like you do work to your face and
if I get bangs you're gonna say I'm
going I'm going through something and
emotionally unstable so it's like and if
you don't get BOTOX it's like oh she
looks real it's like shut up I didn't
even entertain that option no I know but
it's just like that's like the worst
like she's busted
you know she's busted she's old she's
wrinkles so someone who doesn't look
exactly the same as they did in 2007 is
busted yeah that'd be yeah that's a
hologram yeah like uh but also yeah so
it's like I have three shitty options I
might as well pick one and have fun yeah
you know what I mean and it's also good
because then it's like the people that
don't fuck with it like it's a really
easy way to get you out of my life like
it's a really easy way to see who you
are you know
um but uh okay so can I ask
um the play so I got to see you at the
musical in LA and I was like too behind
you and I was like screaming all the
songs oh I loved it and I was trying so
hard to not like ruin your experience
you did not I mean uh spoiler alert I
mean I've seen the show many times so
you know I definitely didn't uh rob me
of my experience seeing Jack a little
bill
um I loved hearing you sing I love when
people sing in the theater in general
like I'm not down with the old rules of
you know theater etiquette gross that's
why I love it Jeremy O'Hara says like go
ahead text during my play yeah yeah it's
just like whatever like it's fine like
fine someone will just fight you in the
parking lot exactly but like yeah I I
love hearing people sing along like it's
a concert I mean it's a it's an
incredible being in there I I being in
watching Jack a little pill with a live
audience is like my favorite form of
church like it's such a great feeling
even knowing that you were writing this
as a as someone that like kind of that
album is a really big like part part of
my um just like daily in her monologue
my belief system my um it's like
imprinted on my DNA I was like it's
gonna be great because it's gonna be all
the songs but like there's no way to
really match
like I was kind of like all the rewrite
the songs I'm sure like it it blew my
mind how well it fit
nothing felt like oh we're stopping to
sing an Atlanta song which I would have
been fine with yeah so would I but the
idea that you're watching this scene
that's like interesting anyway and then
it's just like hey you know like that
worked I gave me chills I just gave
myself chills like it gave me goosebumps
how long did it take to make it all fit
were there any parts where you're like
oh this would feel forced in I mean
here's the thing I will say I was
exceptionally spoiled having that album
to work with because her songs are
inherently like narrative she's telling
stories the song Mary Jane she's telling
a story yeah perfect is the short story
well
um I hear you're losing weight Mary Jane
you ever think about who you're losing
it for was a very big part of my eating
disorder recovery because I couldn't
answer that question because the
question was like uh my ex-boyfriend uh
that girl in high school I'm trying to
make jealous that like I couldn't answer
it right and it's so I felt like as a as
the book writer
compared to some other jukebox musicals
some some other folks really had their
work cut out for them like Mamma Mia to
listen to a bunch of ABBA songs which I
love Abba but it's not like lyrically
how do I put this without pissing off
the abiverse dumb all I have to say is I
think it was very impressive to take the
Abba catalog and make this adorable
rom-com that takes place in Greece and
put it on a Broadway stage anyway I'm
saying that like Alanis I feel like
provided me with so much oh there's so
much was already there that I felt like
it made it easier okay yes and no what
you did is so hard no thank you like I
took years I mean it wasn't like I
dashed it off yes you worked with best
case scenario but it still impossible
what you pulled off
thank you you're welcome it was great
and and to answer your question of you
know was there anything that didn't fit
like yeah like the song not the doctor
is it's a great song I couldn't figure
out what to do interesting and so at one
point I said guys I hate to tell you all
the creative team you know producing
team I was like not the doctor is not
going to be in the show because I don't
know what to do with it at that point we
had workshopped we had you know we were
pretty far along in the process and the
director correctly said to me she's like
you can't leave one song on the album
out people are gonna it's just it's
glaring people want to hear the whole
album if you're doing every track but
not the doctor it's not gonna work I was
like ah so it took a long time to figure
out how to interpolate it into that
therapy scene right and then we did it
um but I remember that being uh probably
the biggest challenge in terms of
placement in terms of you ought to know
just sorry I'm geeking out like was
there pressure of like okay we know
people will be waiting for this song was
there pressure to put it like if we put
it sooner people or let's hold so that
the tension builds and what it does when
they do when they I mean that's probably
the pronoun frankly uh when they do sing
it uh it's gonna be like this explosion
of anticipation I think that my
ignorance of the musical theater process
really helped me with you I don't know
because any person who had any
experience writing for Broadway would
know that you take your big song
your big 11 o'clock number as they call
it and you give it to one of your leads
and this is not to say that Joe isn't an
important character but up until that
point in the show Joe has essentially
been like comic relief kind of like you
know Joe has Joe has been on a journey
but it's not you know the main
characters in the show are Frankie and
Mary Jane so you would assume that one
of them is going to sing you ought to
know and I think giving it to Joe who at
that point has been bottling up that's
what makes it so great just you know
making you know one-liners and to espec
you know the way Lauren Patton
played Joe on Broadway was very much
like just
brushing everything off just you know
whatever like it's all good I don't care
one hand in my pocket right and that and
then I have that explosion in the second
act is like I think that's what and I
mean that's what it felt like to hear
for the first time when we heard it like
what the fuck where did this come from
yeah but that's how anger works right at
least for me it does like I don't people
usually don't know I'm mad until it's
too late yeah yeah so it's like the
volcano you know that's fun and that's
what because that's what it was I felt
like for Atlantis when we heard it's
like every women have been bottling up
their feelings for so long and then it
was just like this explosion out of
nowhere and I think that's how men see
our anger where did this come from yeah
and it's like you because you can't read
the micro expressions of my faces and
then sort of like where did this come
from it's like when my favorite is when
you go out on double date with your guy
and another couple or something and the
woman is like really like mean to you in
a way that only women would understand
yes and then you get in the car and
you're like that was crazy and they're
like what you got what do you mean and
you're like how did you not pick up on
any of that yeah she said I would look
so much prettier without makeup like to
the tape like do you know what I mean
like just little well that's a
compliment I'm like how are you missing
all this you know that's what it felt
like I went on a double date once and
the the lady was like you look so much
thinner in real life
like that's a good one right
because of like sort of what you come
from as a child like the way you're able
to sublimate things into your work and
the way that I feel so lucky that we are
able to and I this is until recently
that I kind of figured out how to you
know this trick of the idea of like
being able to
um essentially alchemize pain
embarrassing moments shitty moments at
parties shitty things people say into
what we do like every time someone is
shitty to me I'm like I just made money
great like it's true do you feel like
when you're moving through the world
you're ever be able to truly be a
participant in society without being
like I'm gonna use that no I was never a
participant I've been a reporter my
whole life
I'm like I'm just an anthropologist no
exactly that is a perfect way to
describe it and I've been saying that
since God and this is like a douchebag
anecdote but like I went on David
Letterman when I was really young he had
read my book about stripping and I had
never been on TV before and he they
called me up and asked me to come on the
show and I said that in in my interview
I said oh I'm an anthropologist I'm like
Margaret Mead that's what I am because
I've always felt that way I'm just
watching other people I don't even know
what it is to be human but I I know what
they do I when I go to parties or events
and someone sees me and it's like hey
Whitney I'm truly stunned because you've
like to personalize I literally think
I'm invisible someone's like hey Whitney
I'm like oh like how did you see me like
I'm staring at you I'm watching your I
mean people say to me all the time
they're like you have to put your your
staring and I'll be like
I just when you showed me the camera
when you were like oh here's you on the
monitor before we get started I was like
oh her like I didn't I wasn't like
that's me it was like oh right it's this
interview person that that comes to town
occasionally apologies that I am putting
you in a situation where Diablo Cody was
talking and now she's not I know that's
traumatic I've
survived I'm mad at you I know me too I
miss talking to her but
I need to talk to you all about
something important smelly balls
this is an important message Grace
you're out there in the field how are
men's uh crevices doing these days have
they have are they buying manscape the
way that they should are they manscaping
it's the landscape is the same as it's
always been it's uh it's rough out there
Bleak yeah razor burn burn I mean just
like bumps is it herpes it's a razor
burn is it monkey pox it can't be too is
that just gum yeah yeah are we are they
they shaving their pubes
they're getting they're getting more
relaxed with it I would like to
single-handedly thank manscape not only
for making products that make men
physically like tolerable because if I'm
gagging around a man I want it for to be
for the right reasons right you know to
make him fall in love with me and I just
I'm grateful I there is a direct
correlation to manscaped making these
incredible freaking products the
deodorant by the way I use if that's
okay
um but there is a direct relationship to
the manscaped company any launching and
me not having had a UTI it's also yeah
it's almost the exact like to the day
like a lot of women I know I'm like we
haven't had UTIs in a while it's like
the date is adding up manscaped really
rescued us on this well guys just like
want to be pampered you know like they
look at all of our skincare products and
they're like secretly jealous well yeah
but it's also like your life will change
okay absolutely we're finally escaping
the heat the leaves are changing pumpkin
spice in the air some call it pumpkin
spice season but when it comes to my man
all I'm thinking about is the fresh fall
ball I love you I even love manscapes
coffee make sure his caramel apples are
smooth and fresh with the help uh don't
bite them though
I'm not no bobbing for apples
unless manscape is the leader in blow
the waist grooming and they are here to
make sure to bring smooth Sensations to
you and the man in your life with 6
million individuals worldwide who trust
manscape for their below the waist
grooming why would you choose anyone
else get manscaped by going to
manscape.com for 20 off plus free
shipping with the code Whitney the
manscape Platinum package 4.0 has
everything the man in your life needs to
freshen up for fall whether gifting it
to your man or a man or using it on your
bikini line let's keep the bush tame
with the lawn mower 4.0 trimmer
manscaped even through in two free gifts
to their Platinum 4.0 the manscape boxer
is cute and the shed travel bag both are
specially made to hold your goodies get
the Platinum package this fall these
products are guaranteed to be hits for
your dangly bits I'm using the deodorant
right now go to manscape.com and get 20
off oh God I love it so good it smells
so good
I can't stand it uh 20 off and free
shipping right with the code Whitney
and free shipping at manscape.com when
you use code Whitney manscaped clear out
the leaves it's your tree trunks time to
shine I love that or twig
I'm back to Diablo Cody and sorry Diablo
do you think any part of that has to do
with the fact that you have your work
name and then you're set so you almost
it's not like alter ego but you're able
to kind of set compartmentalize in a way
that's healthy yes and I've been told by
other people that like they that they
Envy me for that that they're like I
wish I had picked a fake name too so I
could at least have this like separate
you know Google everything for that name
and then I had my own name to myself and
I am protective of you know Brooke Busey
that's who I am the Diablo Cody stuff I
mean it's just like it's a it's funny I
mean it's a funny pen name I have no
idea what was going through my head at
the time I love it but it has been you
know a nice it's just so like she's got
the blues that's what it makes me think
of that was I mean and that was the vibe
right that's what makes me think of um
you know now I'm like old and and
superstitious and I'm like why would I
invoke the devil in my pen name like it
just feels like so stupid but you know I
think most people I'd never even put
that together
I'm glad to hear that I forgot that that
was because it freaks me out I'm always
like God forgive me but yeah but we're
yeah wait is that do you feel what is
your relationship with God now
I have always been religious believe it
or not I just I I have a different
spiritual practice now as an adult than
I did I'm not a Catholic or anything
like that but like I a hundred percent
believe in the interconnectedness of
people and that like our sort of
collective Consciousness is kind of like
God like the the soul of the world is
like a very significant thing I think we
just moved through life feeling very
alone and not realizing that we're
actually like all appendages of the same
body 100 and you know I just connect to
God in different ways and I I mean I'm
like a little it's funny I'm always like
I'm not Catholic anymore and meanwhile
I'm like lighting frankincense every
morning it's like literally dude my
house literally looks like a church I
always have mine by the way the
Aesthetics of religion are gorgeous
Immaculate I have married everywhere in
my house like I have angels I have you
know know it's like totally the gossip
that Gothic that's my Kink same but
maybe it's because of the cathesis of
growing up like I'm sure the first time
I ever like felt vaginal pleasure I was
like in church like what's that and then
was like peel like it's just there's no
way that doesn't you know no I mean it
was like the place where I probably
spent the most time other than my house
so it's like yeah I always feel
comfortable in that culturally Catholic
aesthetic but I actually think that you
know I I'm radically everything's a gift
everything's a gift I'm not saying like
keep hanging out with your abuser or
like glorify adversity like don't come
for me in the comments or come for me
like a shit um but uh uh I do remember I
used to have to sit in church so much
and I went to a Catholic School in
Roanoke Virginia we had we had church
every morning the most gorgeous Church
Old Gothic same here church every
morning yellow beautiful beautiful I
went to a like a gorgeous Eastern
European church I literally loved going
to church because I was like
I would just stare yeah I just loved it
so much and um I remember watching the
priest or the people person giving the
sermon I remember me like I could be do
that better
I remember like I would think of jokes
for everything that none of them were
terrible I mean can you believe they had
the mic for that long why and they were
just like the least interesting people
droning on about whatever I found myself
punching up there's
speeches do you know what I mean and
being like oh he should say that like
you know like and then when he would get
a laugh I'd be like do that more like I
remember having a very clear uh sort of
um Inception of what I ended up doing
later and not really understanding it I
love that that was like
primitive stamina stand up for you I
love looking back at things that you
don't think had a big impact on you and
like I used to um and then when I really
I think started doing stand up like in a
form of like Tourette's of like oh I
don't know how to talk any other way
than to address the awkward thing and
make people laugh because I I don't know
how to have like eye contact just
doesn't work for me uh at that point in
time I just couldn't I couldn't do it
and um I used to be an informal model at
Bloomingdale's and I'd walk around in
like wedding dresses and stuff and be
like I was like a perfume girl basically
but like with wedding dresses like
there's the wedding salon is upstairs if
you want and then people just walk
they're just like they they are creeped
out but everyone wants to avoid the
informal model he's like hey have you
gone upstairs to the trunk show for sure
and it was like excuse me like no one
and I would have to figure out a way to
make a joke I would have to like charm
them I'd have to talk to complete
strangers that did not want me talking
to them you know so I sort of had to
like figure out how to be charming and
funny and then I always got in trouble
they'd be like are you making jokes
about the trunk show are you making fun
of the wedding dress you're wearing I'm
gonna be like yeah it's ridiculous like
you know but so that's kind of how it
started and I go I never thought about
that until kind of recently
that's fascinating like do you feel like
there's anything else that you were
doing as a kid or teenager that was
adjacent to what when writing wasn't yet
your goal where you're like oh well I
mean this is I was already kind of doing
that this is kind of a cliche and I've
heard other people talk about this but
like uh Joey Solway has talked about
this much more articulately than I will
but like the sort of really complicated
games that we created with our dolls and
our ponies and all that stuff like my My
Little Ponies every single one of them
was a specific character with a name yes
right there on top perfect and they all
had different accents they had
backstories and every day I was crouched
down creating these like dramas for my
my ponies and my Barbies and my seawees
and all my little amazing 80s toys and
it's like you don't realize at the time
that you're like writing dialogue you're
exactly it and you're in a theater
I mean it's it scares me a little bit
because I see parents now they're like I
don't know he talks to another and I'm
like that's not in don't let them play
yeah well he's over there talking to
himself good good do not take him to a
therapist right like let him you know I
used to um this is so embarrassing well
I did put Barbies in the microwave and
I'm sorry yeah I mean we all messed with
it I am so sorry but because you know
that remember the brunette Barbie
when they came out with a brunette
Barbie there were a few weren't there
the first one was Whitney oh and it was
like the perfect the brunette Barbie
that did not sell it was like the Pepsi
clear nobody wanted them remember no one
wanted the Whitney doll and so I made a
life-size one I mean that's that's
beautiful and chilling and um uh I
forgot I was gonna say about that but oh
I would interview uh myself I would
write out questions oh I love that as a
journalist and like answer them and I
would like be on top I used to do when
because I was alone so much as a kid I
would do fake commercials like I didn't
even aspire to be in movies I was like
I'm a movie star I would like wrap up
Oscar Mayer or bologna and be like
this is my favorite bologna come on we
watched so many commercials and
commercials where you saw kids so it
made sense you were just like this is
this is what I could be doing so I just
it totally and like that was and I would
like always eat as if I was in a
commercial like loving the cereal or
whatever and then I would make a perfect
bite of like Lucky Charms I'd make sure
it was like three different marshmallows
and whatever just so that because that's
what it would look like in the
commercial and then you were even the
food stylist you were doing every job
everything I was in my mind I was like
someone's filming me and I just want to
make sure we get it like I was just like
a psycho that's I mean I love that I
know that I supposedly I know so many
things are misattributed to Marilyn
Monroe but apparently Marilyn Monroe
like said I always live my life as
though someone is watching me that's it
man that must be exhausting fascinating
yeah and also I do think of so many
people now and I I can't weigh in on
this I know that there's going to be big
psychological impacts from the pandemic
I'm big on like it'll all benefit us
when people like kids are in the mask
and that's not good for them I'm like we
don't know what their future is they
might be being prepared for the life
they're gonna have yeah they might there
might be a version where everyone's
right I don't know I hope not but like
the problem's not gonna get solved until
it's a problem and then we have we just
have to let them prepare for the world
they're gonna live in and not the one we
lived in you know so I I kind of like I
feel a little bit you know I hope I'm
not callous but when people like my kid
has not seen another kid and there's not
playing without I'm like let them play
along let them figure it out let them
develop an inner life let them develop
be it like be able to enjoy themselves
and be creative and have a fantasy world
you know that might be good for for them
yeah because that's what that's how I
did it no it's true and so did I I mean
I preferred that I would have thrived
during a pandemic as a child I know I
feel like this is where I shine yeah
like I don't have to go to school really
Zoom only this is great so can I ask you
what other music was like super like
impactful to you I so when I was like a
freshman in high school I started dating
is probably too uh
I started fooling around with a guy who
was were like a black leather jacket and
smoked and was into Punk and I had no
familiarity with Punk at that point I
listened to like the New Kids on the
Block right who I still love and I but I
he got me you know he made me tapes he
got me into you know Green Day and
screeching weasel and fugazi and you
know the Green Day being punk I'm a
fugazi person that just gave me a lot of
money so you know this was before Green
Day was signed to a major label right
it's always good okay no this was like
that this was like Berkeley era green
accounts this was pre Warner Brothers
pre-dooky we all abandoned Green Day
When that album came out because we were
they had sold out right the dorks didn't
no I know the Dave Matthews fans took
them yeah no no and I love Green Day I'm
just saying like when I say Green Day I
mean they were like playing like garage
shows at that point
um you know so I was into like
um you know all those fucking yeah you
know like
going to all these like basement punk
shows and like it was really
um
it was so healing because it was so the
opposite of this like
aspirational like Saved by the Bell
fucking shit that I had had in my head
up until that point where it was like I
need to be Christy Brinkley I need to be
this I need to be that I need to be
90210 like suddenly it was like oh I can
be Courtney Love I can be Kathleen
Hannah I can be like the names go from
like Tiffany and Stephanie to Roxy and
Rocky yeah and I was like I I was like
oh there's like actually a place for me
and my brand of femininity in this world
and it was uh
it was great and then you went in and
all the punk girls were wearing school
girl uh yeah right plaid skirt it
changed me forever so thank goodness for
that guy that makes me really happy
um in the 90s around the Atlantis air I
have this Theory please argue with me
and tell me I'm wrong because when I see
today I mean I guess every generation
has this with the next generation of
like we've done that that's happened
it's like go back to the you know
ones that actually you're erasing what's
happened I've never had that thought
before but I just turned 40. so here I
am of like people like you know finally
they're strong women in music and like
finally women are like like saying that
you know being angry and I'm like bitch
yeah bitch like what are you doing and
also when people are like oh we're
badasses which I agree with fine I think
but I'm like yeah I was programmed by
women that were like Fuck this I'm not
doing this and then Tori Amos and Alanis
Morissette were like big part of my
programming I love Tori Amos so much
Tori for me is kind of a reason I think
I got into comedy because she was so
obviously dark and real but there was a
playfulness to her of like I'm a
Cornflake Girl Like You can just be
silly yeah and then you can do me and a
gun you know so it's she taught me like
two things can be true at once yeah you
can cope with your sexual assault with
like being playful and silly I just
loved every I would devour every
interview that Tori did because she was
so witty and so weird and she would talk
about how like fairies helped her write
the songs and I was just like I'm so
into this the way that she would play
the piano oh yeah I mean I went I like
toured like followed her everywhere and
she would play the piano in a way that
was I guess you would say masculine but
also kind of like her her legs were so
wide open and it was like she was so
okay with being like ugly in the way
that she sang you know what I mean yeah
it wasn't like I need to make sure that
I'm still cute I was like I'm gonna get
a sound out of me yes that could never
come out of anyone's body if you're not
like contorted in this like oddly sexual
like Primal way and it wound up sort of
paradoxically being like the hottest
thing ever because because she wasn't
pandering to you know a commercial gaze
what do you make of Alanis when
she was doing those videos and sort of
being like
odd
I think that's just her vibe like even
just her Cadence the way that she you
know phrases her lyrics and stuff like
she's she's like a little bit behind the
beat in an interesting way like she's
just that's what makes her great
honestly if I think that she moved in a
typical way or saying in a typical way
she wouldn't be the sort of tightness
that she is I just she's just like she's
a weirdo a weirdo in a way that I don't
even know if you could do today like
when you look back at those videos where
she's kind of like it's almost she's
like I'm gorgeous and I'm talented but
like no concept of the male gaze and
that she had come from this pop
background where she was absolutely you
know expected to look a certain way be a
certain weight like the makeup the hair
it was very 80s pop you know her
Canadian era pop era and then so I think
she was just ready to be done with it I
love watching old concerts of her in her
20s where she's she's literally wearing
like an old baggy t-shirt and corduroys
and her hair is loose and long and she's
just running around the stage whipping
her hair around and there was there's no
attempt at like stage costuming do you
know what I mean it's like she rolled
off the bus and ran onto the stage and I
think it's the coolest thing I have it
had never occurred to me at the time
that you didn't dress for male approval
I mean you're on TV not trying to appeal
to men like I blew my mind like I didn't
even understand what was happening I
know well that's why the riot girl stuff
was also like really valuable to me
because it was just like oh this is like
this feels like it's for the girls like
it feels like you're dressing to like
Delight other women as opposed to or you
know other people as opposed to just the
fucking straight guys that just like
blew my mind her first video she's just
in a white sheer button down I guess
that helps that's good they're probably
you could wear white shirt but has to be
sheer yeah exactly maybe those are the
compromises you can wear pants but they
have to be tight and leather I'm sure
she would tell us all about if she was
here so she's like I can go through the
Wardrobe decisions for you I don't know
video like yeah I think she's coming on
the 23rd of October when she's here um
okay so I'm gonna ask you a question
that was sent from Kathleen uh Kathleen
Gallagher uh Catherine Gallagher uh it
was in the original run and is a good
friend of mine and she's incredible
beyond beyond brilliant uh she's asking
is there an Atlanta song that's not in
the musical that you wish was
no because you were just doing all the
ones from that album yeah but we even
brought in ones that aren't on the album
you know like honestly I
like give me
give me okay take your time
um I love I love the song unsent where
she's reading the letters yes yes and
but there was no actual way to make that
work in the context of the show unless
we had like written new letters which we
I suppose we could have you know what I
mean like yes applied to the narrative
and but that I listened to that one a
lot it makes me cry all the time
um also let me say something about going
to see Jag a little pill the musical
when the intermission came there was
like a panic in the audience that was
over I love that there was a panic
there's like a panic we're all like wait
a second no no it's happening that would
not be that's not it right I've never
gone to a musical and not at the
intermission but like great I'm good
no one got up like no one got up they
were just like what is happening like
um okay so uh do you have a favorite
memory from the rehearsal room working
on JAG a little pill she says my
personal favorite was the day I realized
we'd be best friends because I sat next
to you and your computer had Taylor
Swift I think it was the red jay red
album up on the screen but what's yours
um the Catherine and Derek Lena who
played uh the role of Nick on Broadway
had a little show that they did together
in their dressing room and up for
Instagram and they invited me on one day
and I actually felt like I had been
invited into like the sanctuary do you
know what I mean because as the writer
you don't really hang out in the
dressing rooms and you don't like really
get to be invited into that part of it
and like getting to sit and hang out
with them I felt like I was very cool
and they're like young and I was like am
I young maybe am I young today and then
it's like no no no no no you're in your
40s but like it was it it Catherine
knows that was a very precious memory
for me and from the rehearsal room
um man
the first time this is like not like a
light-hearted memory but the first time
I saw Predator which is a scene that
sort of recounts a sexual assault that
has happened at a party which is a very
delicate thing to put on a Broadway
stage and choreograph and Catherine had
to do it every night
and the first time I saw the number
honestly I think everybody was I mean I
just had to leave yeah it was so
powerful and I thought what are we doing
like I had no idea I'm getting chills
right now just telling you about it I
just thought oh my God like we're gonna
do this for audiences and
it's Brave Tori Spelling has a question
I love Tori Spelling hi Tori
she says did you like the one-of-a-kind
designer outfit that Donna Martin made
for you and did you get to keep it also
do you still love me Tori I still love
you I think you're incredible I'm I'm
like I love you I love your beautiful
family
um you're an icon I ha I still have the
dress that Donna Martin made for me and
this is from the CW it was custom made
for me and of course I kept it and
um the the Wardrobe lady called me fat
uh which was an amazing experience
um she measured my waist to make the
dress and then she um or the it was the
assistant it wasn't the me it wasn't
your main costumer but the assistant
measured my waist and said like
you're very big
and then the main the main costume lady
yelled at her and but that's one of that
was my take away from that experience
because now I feel like people are a
little more inclusive but back then like
if you were a size eight if you had a 29
inch waist like I do whoa
what are you doing at 90210
wow yeah was that happened to me more
than once though like I've had like when
I was I was in Vogue like back in 2012
and the they literally came back to redo
my measurements because the girl said
that they had to be wrong
I had one time I was doing uh at
Bloomingdale's uh I was of informal
modeling at Bloomingdale's no big deal
and what other fucking name not uh
Victor and roll if I love Badgley Mishka
the actual designers came and this was
when like a local this is at like King
of Prussia Mall outside Philadelphia
it's like not glamorous at all but they
come because this is where they get
their money from like the rich women
that you know will actually show up they
want to meet the designer and then
they'll buy some things from the
collection that no one can fit into
they'll watch a model wear it in a size
zero and they'll go right I'll order
that'll and then they'll custom make it
for them right right these women that
just have an ungodly amount of money so
I would stand there and I would just
model for all these really rich women
this is what it looks like on me I mean
I I haven't eaten in three weeks but
like
this is what it looks like on on uh
skeleton yeah um if you're curious if
you want to be buried in it or something
I don't know like why would you need to
see this at all and then I remember one
of them they were trying to zip it up
and it was a size zero and they just
couldn't zip it up and he goes you're
just her ribs are too big her ribs are
just too big for this dress like you
have anything to do with your rib cage
circumference of course and I remember
being like the fact that you can see my
ribs is already weird
like my skeleton is too big for you you
know what I mean like it was just
psychotic and I just remember being like
I feel like you don't have to say it
like that feels like something you think
and you can glance at each other but to
say it out loud and then I was like
maybe I am invisible no one can see me
yeah no I know it's like it's the people
I definitely had a lot of uh
and I can tell you that stylists
definitely did not want to work with me
um I don't really go out anymore so
that's not a concern but when I did it
was like oh no she's an eight she's a 10
forget about it that's psychotic that's
how it is though even with like actual
fucking like you know big celebrities
like I've heard Bryce Dallas Howard has
talked about how she has to buy her own
stuff off the rack because she's not a
sample yeah and then the last movie they
asked her to lose weight Jurassic Park
today yeah and Chris Pratt I think stood
up for whatever but I was just like wild
um do you think that movie critics
matter anymore
yeah um but I think their jobs have
become very difficult because the public
opinion has begun to just override
everything like social media is just
gonna drown out any sort of you know um
critical opinion I guess
um
so
I don't know I guess I guess in a sense
I have I have sympathy for the critic
because it's uh kind of a Dying art in a
way like it's really I not I don't think
um formal reviews are what our driving
ticket sales anymore but I also think
when I look at a movie like Jennifer's
Body which is an iconic like people
honestly I could have made I could have
made a Flawless film and that movie
would have been Torn to Pieces no but
but it's something was torn to pieces
and then people started watching it and
then word of mouth was like oh no we
love this critics confused threw us off
the trail they were wrong oh yeah do you
know what I mean or whatever I don't
even I don't remember reading the
reviews I never like thought about all
that I've heard you sort of talk and
going oh like movies that critics were
wrong about now people are finding and
going this is fucking brilliant iconic
life-changing I mean a lot of people
hated it like non-critic people hated it
at the time too though because we tested
that movie multiple times and I I still
have the car so the kindness they were
so Savage you're telling me the kind of
people that it would go to his test
greeting for 50 bucks cash it did not
care for the film yet didn't understand
art the meth addicts that needed 50
bucks before they started having DTS in
Vegas are you telling me they're not
thinking clearly I genuinely genuinely
hate that process you know what's odd
about it as a stand-up I kind of like am
torn because I love it on some level
because I'm like audience decides oh
that makes sense they decide they're our
boss but then I go the process with
which you do it it's why some science to
me is wonky because it's like like
they're coming in and the questions are
so did anything confuse you about the
movie like people just want to help
people just want need to have an answer
I'll say seem dumb like when you're in
those focus groups of like so is there
anything you didn't like about the Megan
Fox character you're like
um yeah actually like you just think you
need to Ace the test no you're right
it's like the whole system is completely
flawed and the worst thing is you if you
have like two kids from you know Buena
Park say that they thought a character
was too bitchy the studio will literally
the next day be like okay we need to get
back into the editing room and we need
to find some takes where you know Leslie
is more likable and it's like because of
freaking Jaden and Caitlyn said I don't
like like that's the part that it's not
likable that they think she's bitchy
yeah they have internalized misogyny or
whatever it is or whatever I mean but
then you know it's it's a fascinating
process like when we test I know I'm not
babbling now but when we tested Ricky in
the flash what was really interesting is
like older men really liked the movie
and the Ricky character and older women
Savaged it because they were like she's
so selfish she's a bad mother yeah I
would and it's because they weren't
comfortable with the idea of like oh
maybe I gave up too much yeah of course
it was 100 like internalized shit coming
out like okay I gave up everything for
my kids and so should Meryl Streep Hey
so uh you made me look in the mirror yes
and you made me look at myself yes and I
just I'm not there yet yeah I would like
to just keep coasting along this
delusional sort of like lifestyle and
you're making me confront my feelings
and it's curious how dare you yes which
by the way for some people going to
movies it's like there is this version
of like I almost think we need a rating
for this movie is going to make you
uncomfortable like think it's gonna
challenge you or like you're just gonna
check the fuck out this is a check the
fuck out movie this is a not like it's
almost like you're right though like
that's how we should categorize movies
in general because sometimes I'm in the
mood to think and sometimes I want to
check the fuck out right but if I'm
ready to check the fuck out and then all
of a sudden I'm having to think about
these uncomfortable things I'm like oh
shit I I just needed a heads up and I
would have watched this at a different
time with a different person you know
what I mean like I would this wouldn't
have been my like birthday drunk night
like I'm wearing it I'm wearing a dick
Tiara like I thought this let's go see
an Adam Sandler movie I'm sorry you know
or like the ones that are just him Adam
Sandler's tricky because so my 12 year
old loves you know Billy Madison and he
loves Happy Gilmore but so sometimes
he'll go through Netflix no he'll put
him he'll put on like exactly and then
he'll say to me he'll be like I watched
the Adam Sandler movie today that just
wasn't funny and I'm like you can't
click on it just because it says Adam
Sandler and you wind up watching Reign
Over Me yeah I
I am so obsessed with Adam sand I'm
obsessed with your career I'm obsessed
with Adam Sandler because I love that
he's like I can do the Oscar stuff I
just want to go to Hawaii and hang out
with my wife and have fun with comedians
yeah like this is I I'm having fun doing
this
he is the epitome of like one for me one
for them like and it's he just he has
the most perfect career
um what makes someone see a movie so I
think marketing is kind of broken for a
couple reasons number one
um I looked up because I remember the
movie Paradise that you directed I
remember when that came out reading the
script I mean when the script was out it
was like this is just so fucking and
then I hadn't seen like the poster and I
just now like this morning Google I
don't remember what the poster was
there's a poster that made me angry and
I know because once you make the movie
at least at that time there was like an
art Department kind of takes over and
they're like we need to test all these
posters like a lot of posters like I
mean Netflix you know as a different
poster for every algorithm you know so
if you're a gay man they'll you know for
glow it'll be Allison Brie and sparkly's
roller skates you know it's straight man
it'll be her like in a bra like they
know what they're doing oh I know I've
been in those marketing meetings where
they're like here's six options men like
number three the best like yeah there
was uh uh hold on Paradise movie it was
one that was like sort of it just was
like with this new line movie poster for
the Phoebe Cates Willie Ames Movie
Paradise comes up
um I don't I think there's been a few
movies called that anyway I it was
definitely the one that like they did
that was like a new line like New Year's
Eve Valentine's Day that just had famous
oh yeah yeah yeah just famous people oh
yeah totally yeah you know what I mean
it's the DVD yeah but we were kind of
like this doesn't feel like a Diablo
Cody movie with on this poster
yeah I guess not I mean I was just sort
of like
I I don't know yeah it's like yeah
famous people I for some reason I think
because I had just had a baby when that
movie dropped I like was just so checked
out that but you don't I don't think
there's certain but even if you weren't
like they're like this is the one we
need for planes sorry like this is the
one we need for Delta this is the one we
need for whatever that's what they do
and so I think we're at a point where I
kind of the more a movie is marketed the
more I'm like why are you pushing this
so hard like it's almost like it used to
be like oh my God there's Billboards
everywhere I gotta go see this now
you're kind of like why are you yeah I
trust it makes you suspicious when
there's too much marketing you're like
wait a minute like do you need to sell
this this hard is it bad like 100 and I
think most people are like that now I'd
rather one person I respect being like
Oh my God I saw a pearl the other night
you have to fucking see it if you told
me to do that I'd be like I gotta go
watch that where's my sub 50 Billboards
I'd be like maybe go get it that's
definitely changed I mean for me like I
know you didn't ask this but the biggest
failure of marketing that I've
experienced was actually not Jennifer's
Body even though that was certainly
botched Tully was a really sad one for
me because they they released it on
Mother's Day I would say I like the
stick I love the stickers on that poster
I know I love the poster the poster is
great amazing the trailers were great
but I love the movie the problem was
they decided to release it on Mother's
Day and Market it as a romance like a
not a romantic comedy but like a comedy
about motherhood and women went to see
it and I literally had to give a formal
apology in the New York Times because of
how many women were triggered by the
film because they thought they were
going to see something fun on Mother's
Day and it like completely
re-traumatized them from their PPD or
whatever hold on okay let me give a
formal apology in the New York Times
we're taking a break real quick because
it is important that you guys understand
I'm not good at a lot of things and
that's okay with me but something I am
good at
is understanding how shirts work
and a lot of them don't work I'm seeing
a lot of dorky ass hats and I'm seeing a
lot of dorky ass t-shirts t-shirts
worked in the 70s and 80s and then in
the 90s they started making them
see-through and v-neck and relax relax
it's a t-shirt you don't reinvent the
wheel I don't need a dragon a bedazzled
Dragon Ed Hardy took us down a wild Road
okay wild Road I have to go on eBay and
Etsy normally to get vintage t-shirts
because first of all the ones that are
being made now they're a hundred and
forty dollar first of all or they're
made of paper why is it see-through I
don't why what are we doing who's making
these yeah who like I'm sorry that we
don't have wet t-shirt contests anymore
that doesn't mean you need to just start
making was there some kind of like
collusion where like let's just make all
women's t-shirts see-through
absolutely what else are we gonna do now
because we can't like yeah
so true classic it is a completely
different kind of men menswear brand I
wear it too sometimes is that okay
absolutely I
cannot tell you how soft this is it's
making me crazy it is a closer fit in
the arms and chest to highlight your
guys best assets and a little room in
the Torso to keep things cozy and
streamlined because you know what your
guy is not Jack Sparrow oh I was gonna
say cozy and streamline
yeah exactly my invisible boyfriend turn
man from sandpaper and do a teddy bear
plus all of their styles are super soft
and affordable I'm saying this their
copy isn't no weird randomly big Maroon
5 Adam Levine
collarbone showing shirts no holes on
purpose no v-necks down to your belly
button like let's just be adults okay
with the olds Rowdy t-shirts he's been
hanging on to since varsity volleyball
which also if your guy played varsity
volleyball we're having a bigger
conversation that's a different
conversation for another time yeah
you've got to get these for the band in
your life it this is a gift he will
actually love we have an exclusive deal
for our listeners we want to hook you up
with some true classic friends and we
want you to hook up with a man that
doesn't feel like a Brillo pad please if
you wear a true classic you know me I'm
on Instagram damn me for a limited time
only get 25 off with the code Whitney
trueclassic.com true classic looks great
on all body types you can shop chew
classic with confidence knowing you've
got his base is covered and they are
size inclusive any of the bigger boys
out there we love a dad bod they also
have long body options for the tall guys
and up to xxxl on their staple collars
now I'm just jealous of your boyfriend
uh get comfortable get going and upgrade
your guys wardrobe with two
true classic get 25 25 off that's a lot
that's a lot off at trueclassic.com with
code Whitney free shipping included on
purchases over a hundred dollars I just
realized how fucking much of a racket
shipping is so that's a steal 100
risk-free guarantee with 30-day return
policy if only men came with the same
policy true classic you're that good get
25 off true classic we promo code
Whitney and true classic tees.com
Whitney exclamation point hashtag true
classic pod back to Diablo
it's so you've apologized and Bill Cosby
has it yeah yes I have apologized and at
the time I was pissed off because I was
like I was like the point of film is to
provoke and to you know in some ways
re-traumatized like I I can't apologize
for triggering people that's why I got
into this business but you can't like
trick them you tricked them the studio
tricked them this you didn't I'm sorry
I'm at the studio you try but okay this
is so I did apologize that they were
tricked so you know that I
um my biggest cause at the moment is
Justice for Shirley Temple
so
so we people are like is Hollywood like
just creepy I'm like it was built on the
back of a five-year-old toddler that was
put in blackface like we they're like
they're there's there's
um
atrocities in this business like Shirley
Temple was like good shit like was
dancing for men not a mom and is there a
mom is there a babysitter like there's
no women in this movie why is she at War
emotionally supporting soldiers like I'm
in a diaper like I'm confused but the
point is uh there's I of all the
Hollywood that might be one of the more
fucked up things I've heard and I know a
lot about fucked up things in this
business like like um uh the director
slapping um what was Dorothy's name in
The Wizard of Oz
he slapped her because she wouldn't stop
laughing in a scene when she was 15 he
slapped her in the face like things
where you're just like that's despicable
disgusting people just caught on fire in
that movie that movie was like a
disaster people got lung cancer the the
Tin Man got lung cancer from the the
zinc or whatever it was um uh they like
used asbestos as the makeup you know it
was like wild so someone um the
Scarecrow had all these scars Forever on
his face from you know the they use like
fish line you you know I also had to
like sleep on a plank because he
couldn't like sit in the costume or
something like it was crazy why but I'm
saying that to release Tully to be like
we should put this out on mother that is
wildly unfair that's a level yeah yeah I
mean I was like I feel like this is a
fall movie guys I feel like this is 100
depressing movie Season movie
um but I think they just wanted to get
it out I think they were worried that it
wasn't going to perform very well so
they were like let's at least take
advantage of one hook that we have
um you know we should do take advantage
of moms and the movie did underperform I
mean but I
you know that was that was crazy to me
because I was just like why this is like
this is like a pretty Grim movie I think
you're one of my favorite uh writers and
and
sort of Visionaries because you it
reminds me of the comeback is my
favorite TV show you know I love the
comeback and know when it came out it
was like this is just too uncomfortable
this is just too much
she's being she's humiliating herself
too it's too cringy like we can't
process it like it wasn't
um it was just operating on a level that
was just like incredibly like
sophisticated but it never compromised
it's like we're gonna I mean that finale
of season one when she is talking about
having the rod in her back and having to
sit on the bench for the uh the field
hockey team you know there's not even a
cut in it it's just sort of it is so
relentless like you are gonna feel this
grant like you're good we will not let
you look away like you do that and then
in 10 years people are like this is the
most brilliant thing ever made and it
just happened to be made 10 years ago
well that's the funny thing that happens
to me is I can't tell you you know 15
years ago when I started out in the
business how many pitches or how many
projects I was told like oh you know
this woman is too unlikable this one and
now they're like begging for it they're
like oh can you give us something we
want something with a girl a woman who's
just a complete mess like a wreck
unlikable train wreck and I'm like now
you want that see that annoys the
fucking other women have their shit
together we want them you want that but
you weren't willing to well I couldn't
sell that to you in 2008 no you had to
be nice and fuckable well no because now
women have any kind of progress now we
need them to be degraded you know I
hadn't even considered that angle for me
it was like oh now we it's we realize
it's safe because so many projects have
succeed it's the only thing you'll allow
so when women weren't in the workplace
we had Ally McBeal we had all these
lawyers we had all these fucking women
doctors and now it's like they have to
be addicted to pills they have to be
fucking their sister they have to be
anally fucked while like it's just like
I mean it's part of the reason I'm like
with TV I'm like you know any woman that
kind of has her shit together and is
smart or has good advice or anything is
just like sorry the only good advice
women are allowed to give is like you
know what you need a makeover like well
like in Soul cycle yeah little talks in
an exercise class like what are you
talking like it just drives me fucking
insane that that's and also the biggest
note of Like This Woman's not likable
you don't like women you just admitted
it yeah exactly how do you not see how
Wild that is well that she's not likable
to you you just admitted I don't like
what like it's like wild that we're like
oh that's a good point
um no one likes her like I like her I
totally exactly like I wrote this
because I like her yeah I like her
people like her you don't like her
I know I'm saying something you know but
no I know but we would take that note
and she's like okay yeah I'll make her
okay great we'll have her rescue a cat
from a tree or like whatever the fuck
thing yeah I mean I it's funny like it
also you haven't seen it performed
yeah you exactly like you're doing is
going to bring so much you're doing the
bitchy performance in your head you did
that well I have to give that note all
the time on notes calls I'm always like
well do you understand that when we we
haven't you know an actor doing this
they're going to bring nuance and warmth
and humor to this line and you'll see
the pain that made them bitch not just
you know but that's you know what are
you gonna do
a lot of things uh what is the worst
note you have gotten on a project and
you don't have to say who it is or what
the project is uh I wrote a project year
years ago I mean I want to say it was
for like UPN I kid you not and yeah my
first job was on up half and half the
show called half and a half yeah no I
mean that's this that's back in the day
and I had written a whole pilot about
that took place in a law office and they
said that they were cool with it but
everyone should be a dentist so I
changed the whole show to be in a
dentist's office from a law office and
that's still funny to me because I don't
know why everybody suddenly I don't like
I I don't know that was a good one and
then oh this is a classic by the way I
lawyers are funny
try to be funny to be clear I know
nothing about law or Dentistry so either
way it was just like complete hack
bullshit from 25 year old me but then
the um also UPN best Note ever
especially in light of today was I I
insinuated that a character might be
bisexual in a in a teen pilot I was
writing and they said they called me and
they said we specifically need to talk
to you about something we don't do gay
here we will we do not do anything gay
we don't do gay characters that's just
100 not on the table for us and now it's
like who's gay but you're a closeted gay
man no I mean it was probably an openly
gay man that said it to me to be
perfectly honest with you like but that
it's funny to me now because it's like
oh my God if you said that like what is
this like Hallmark
shocking yeah that is wild
um I'm obsessed with uh iconic roles
that were almost played by another actor
oh I like that too like Sandra Bullock
almost was a Million Dollar Baby instead
of uh Hillary Swang Nicole Kidman was
almost Notting Hill uh I didn't know
that one yeah uh Russell Crowe was
almost the Lord of the Rings guy Emilia
Clark was almost Anastasia from 50
Shades of Gray like I love that
um Love Actually no uh um Buena Paltrow
was almost Rose from the Titanic oh I
knew that one like are there any like
people not like they didn't get it
because they shut liquor is there
anything they just couldn't do it or
whatever or they couldn't do it or you
just it ended up not being the you know
or someone that you wrote with in mind
and then you're like Ah that's not the
right person I'll work with them
eventually but like just
um I did right I did not know Charlize
Theron at the time that I wrote young
adult and I did write it with either in
my mind I was like this is Gwyneth
Paltrow Reese Witherspoon I can't
picture it really I mean Charlie's
obviously is like born to play that part
and once I had met her yeah
but I didn't I hadn't I didn't
specifically have her in mind when I was
writing it
um everything else I've written for her
I have but and then um you would imagine
Reese and then you kind of vastly like
go back and forth and this is not like
that interesting but Luke Wilson was
originally going to play the Jason
Bateman part in Juno and he left he
dropped out like a week before like it
was like no offense but thank God
Bateman came in like a last minute as
like a favor so that I remember that
because I was scared at the time I was
like the movie's finally getting made
and we don't have a guy to play mark
That's a trip yeah to think about just
the sliding doors of all that shit yeah
yeah I'm obsessed pretty much and then
can I ask your takes on a couple movies
like I think you are
um you just I don't know I put you in
the same categories like Chuck
Klosterman oh I know I love Chuck yeah
my favorite yeah just in terms of like a
90s writer Aficionado of culture where I
think culture is so subjective and I
love that you know a singer that I love
you hate great that would be weird if we
all love the same art because we're it's
a Rorschach test we're projecting our
shit you know but like your point of
view I'm always like I want to know what
she thinks and I okay tell me what what
what what do you want my opinion
Twilight
um so I did see all the movies or like
just your experience with it
um you know it's weird it's like I feel
like I would have a stronger opinion if
I'd been a little bit younger or a
little bit older I was in this exact
pocket of like what was our Twilight
oh that's my this is my thing everything
now has always existed it just looked
different I love like what was our
Twilight who was our JoJo siwa was
Titanic kind of our Twilight yeah it was
just one probably I think it probably it
was I think it was just emotion porn we
had a JoJo siwa because I'd argue that
JoJo who I love also she was at Jack a
little pill I think she was born out of
a new the New Media era the online the
YouTube era and we didn't have that yeah
but like
I mean we had like Paulie Shore we I oh
wait did that saying Paulie Shore was
our JoJo siwa is the hottest take and I
love it I'm just
saying JoJo siwa's handing out like
souvenirs to the people she fucks I
might be wrong okay
his sex life aside okay I just mean when
I first saw Polly he was kind of just
this like I'm here to entertain you yeah
I don't totally know who you are when
you're not performing but you are just
Pee-wee Herman minus the jerking off
I've never had a Peewee before since
Peewee is singular it's true
I just oh you want to know something
crazy someone who is pure negativity no
I have a crazy one for you though give
it I think
Paris Hilton has actually become a
Pee-Wee Herman type figure and I don't
mean that as shade I mean she is playing
a full-time beloved character and you
know what I think Paris Hilton comes
from what Lisa Frank
I mean obviously she's she's Marky than
unicorn you know what I mean it's like
it's sort of Barbie Barbie yeah a little
but I do think like Paris is really uh
grown on me as a figure because at this
point what she is doing has become an
eccentricity as opposed to a performance
of you know
mainstream sexuality like at this point
it's become like she's been doing it so
long and is so committed to it and it's
become such Camp yeah that almost
reminds me of like Angeline Peewee John
Waters yes John Waters more so than like
oh this blonde girl is so perfect
Angelie and I have the um uh that's a
Polaroid camera Angelina up to the left
harder oh yeah it's an Angeline I love
Angela yeah Angeline I love her so much
I paid 80 for one of her shirts out of
the back of her car I would do that yeah
I don't think I've ever caught her
stopped you know you see her
I had asked you on the road but I don't
think I've ever had a meeting with her
at Denny's it was the wildest hour she
met my friend at Denny's too I think
that she just meets people at Denny's is
that her thing she yes that is her thing
and she is so eccentric and just there's
nothing to compare to there's no way to
like understand what's happening you're
just um
I was like we're in a simulation that's
the first time I was like wearing a
simulation Angela Angeline made that
shit happen for herself without
Instagram without I mean it's just like
I respect it obsessed she was like I
don't have a product but let's get me
that billboard what are you selling me
like just my great but she said some
things to me that you know when someone
just says something to you where you're
like you're right and no one would have
the audacity to say it but it's a great
observation just
no one would say that she looked at me
and she was like you look like a cartoon
oh she said that and I was like
you're right I mean that's a compliment
it totally I I just took I just was like
that's true that explains so many things
like babies really like me and I had a
PDA uh what is called pediatrician once
say oh it's because you look like a baby
to them like the way you're you have big
eyeball like there's a word for it
neotness I think it's the word really
yeah Pat can you check that that is
amazing
features it means you're you're
symmetrical and childlike yeah baby I
have like a giant smile so I look like a
remix of like a baby and a clown and
it's just like and it just all like just
makes a lot of sense but it helped me
because I was like a lot of times as a
stand-up I'm like having to project I
have to do so much less than I think I
have to do because my face is so
expressive yeah and I just it took me a
while to like if I think I'm being
subtle I have to do half
it's a weird it's a weird thing that
like it feels self-obsessive to even
think about but I'm able to think about
myself in a really objective way and I'm
always desperate for how to know how I'm
perceived but no one has the balls to
tell you it's funny that
like I got more done with you at Denny's
than like any therapist I've ever worked
yeah
um can I ask you some questions from
fans of course I can't believe there's
fans you are fans no they're your fans
yeah really nice
um uh it's a lot of Jennifer's Body I
had to yeah why isn't on iTunes
no that like I I can't do anything about
it okay great thank you yeah and uh
Jennifer's Body did she this is me did
she really swim in that fucking Lake
yeah that is the most wild shit and she
was Paparazzi by like crazy ass like
long run stalkers that day too which
caused a huge crisis onset it was bad
like it's so wild how famous she's been
for so long I know I know what music are
you currently enjoying
you know what's funny I just want to
know so like one of a really weird
things sometimes where I'll take an
artist that I don't know anything about
but that is popular and I will dive into
their catalog and listen to it over and
over so I can try and figure out this
again this is a weird I'm not really a
person thing I'm more trying to research
the phenomenon of the artist and um I
decided to do it recently with Miranda
Lambert because I didn't know anything
about Miranda Lambert but I knew what
Miranda Lambert's like shtick was yeah I
know like what she is and what she means
to people and what her images so I went
online I went on her subreddit I
compiled what people said were her best
songs I made a Spotify playlist and I've
been listening to Miranda Lambert in my
car
researching how's it going it's great I
I think I'm a Miranda Lambert ballads
person I don't really go as much for the
like root and tootin interesting but
Bluebird is an amazing song wow and she
writes her own music right yeah I think
so yeah yeah I think so too but it's uh
yeah I just always want to know if
somebody has a mask like a huge yep yep
I'm I'm curious about them even if it's
not necessarily my bag what was what are
some other ones you've done this with
um this is fascinating so this is funny
I always was so interested in the
Grateful Dead fandom right
and years ago I was like all right don't
overthink it so I was like No it's it's
too late Whitney it's too late pretty
simple no it's too late they got me they
got me stoned they got me do Ayahuasca
and it started as like just oh I'm gonna
force myself to listen to the Grateful
Dead all the time and it and then it
then suddenly it wasn't forced anymore
and suddenly all I wanted to listen to
music and suddenly it's a cult I know
and now I go to all the done company
shows and it's like yeah I love Grateful
Dead I would love to know as uh a um
musical Anthropologist your take on fish
that's where I'm like I Grateful Dead I
can figure out but the fish thing that's
drugs I never got into fish remember
we're bouncing around the room
what's happening why are these songs 45
minutes like this is not this is a cult
I know I never allowed myself to because
you know there's there's all those
Grateful Dead adjacent acts like like
fish and like yep you know whatever
Widespread Panic or you know I I never
allowed myself to Adventure outside the
margins of the dead because I know I
would wind up like
next thing you know I'm like spinning in
circles that's so fascinating wasn't
Jonah Hill gonna play him or is playing
Jerry Garcia I'd kill to see that movie
wow yeah what uh movies do you want to
see that are based on real people oh man
um you know what I it's I if there was a
way to do it in a way that wasn't
exploitative
where's our Britney Spears biopic well
you know what I mean like wouldn't you
want to see that
who would it be
I don't know past Jamie Lynn I remember
there was a story about Neil Strauss
wrote about in one of his books that he
went to spend a few days with Brittany
once and she like completely
spilled her guts to him yeah and then
nothing came of it and I was like I'd
see a movie of like a few days of Neil
Strauss and Britney Spears hanging out
together in Britney Spears like giving
him her entire life story so like a year
ago I did this it was like sort of
before her conservative conservatorship
is over which was I just happened to
know a lot about conservatorships
because I have uh you know when you have
right or the power of attorney of people
in rehabs and uh nursing homes and
people both my parents had strokes and
it's really for people that are aging
that so that people don't take advantage
of them and change their will like
that's really it's very unusual for
someone Britney's age to be and actually
in the state of California in order to
get a conservatorship the person if I
want to get a conservatorship on you
you go to court and if you can tell me
your name the date and who the president
is it's a non-starter it's not even a
conversation you have to have a
relationship with reality that is so far
gone that you don't know your name the
date or the president they actually pull
it off then that's what I'm saying so
they ask you those three questions and
if I say no but she drunk drove with my
kids in the car and she hit a school bus
but they're like great those are crimes
we'll send her to jail but that's not a
conservatorship she still is able to
process reality the same way that's how
fucking wild it is so we did this thing
on the show which because most I was
like what is the root of this problem uh
is that people have signed ndas and
they're scared so of all this it doesn't
that one guy the father can't keep her
in there there's a staff of 30 people
that are making this happen right
putting the pills down her throat making
sure she doesn't have her phone like a
lot of people are a part of this machine
and they're not saying any they've seen
a lot of crazy shit they participate in
a lot of crazy shit and they're afraid
of being sued because they signed an NDA
most ndas don't hold are illegal I've
seen his it's does it will not hold up
in court number one worst case scenario
you're going to play pay an NDA
violation fee which usually isn't more
than five thousand dollars right in
order to he would have to sue you which
would cost him a ton of money he's not
going to and it would make him look
guilty so I did this whole thing that
was if you have worked for Brittany in
any capacity or him and you know stuff
and you're worried about the NDA I will
pay your legal fees and I will it won't
come to that and I'll pay your NDA
violation fee and I did this whole thing
about how ndas work and how they they're
it's just kind of a mirage yeah of a
super powerful scary person and you sign
this thing and he'll go like well you
signed that NDA so I can fucking take
your house and put a lien on your house
and take your children none of it's true
it was just like a empty threat but most
people don't know that so uh after that
every Hotel I would go to cleaning
ladies would be like hey I worked for
Brittany in Vegas and they would like
tell me the wildest shit oh wow you know
so I had I was in Portland at the whole
hoxton the whole box of the hoxton I
think it's called the hoxton and this
one um it's cleaning lady told me
because I also always talk to the
cleaning ladies anyway you know I'm
always like you know they're in your
room I'm like you know and they want to
come to a comedy show or something and
um and she was like I worked uh I was
her cleaner for her room when she was
doing Planet Hollywood in Vegas and
she's like I was the cleaning lady I
walked in to security guards when I was
between them at all times I had to give
my phone Brittany I wasn't allowed to
talk to Brittany they were with me this
is just to clean the room the entire
time Brittany did not have a phone like
she there was just like all the shit and
you're like it was just mind-blowing it
was mind-blowing well some guy broke his
NDA recently who worked on the piece of
me show and wrote about it online and it
was really quite elucidating I mean it
was like she yeah I mean I don't
understand how they could make this
woman perform while simultaneously
asserting that she couldn't
you know drive a car well because then
you saw how her performances started
becoming more and more lifeless and more
and more like one time to show and it
was very sad yeah it was that vma's
performance when she was just kind of
like a rag doll it was like weekend of
Bernies you're just like she's like not
there you know like Britney Spears is
not capable of giving a bad performance
if she wants to give a good one
yeah I see what you're saying and it
really is like it just it makes me so
sad it makes me so sad because it's like
I honestly unironically I'm a Brittany
fan you know and I and also she's a
fucking like boss like I hate when do
people say that when she's a boss like I
hate strong women that's redundant
whatever but like watching her like
behind the scenes shit and watching her
run shit and like have the I I think I
assumed oh there must be 50 people at uh
that do all this and she's like this
puppet like I think I always thought
that and then when you see the footage
of her actually doing everything herself
you're just like holy shit I think you
can only be puppeteered to a certain
level and if you get past that level
it's like that's a certain kind of like
she'd be JLo now yeah that's a honestly
probably Beyond
did you watch that JLo documentary I did
it was interesting
I thought it was interesting because I
was like wow like
JLo is
she the thing I thought was so cool
about it was like like JLo like is so
aware of her Fame and is like constantly
monitoring it like it's like
there's like there's the the image is
constantly being
um either like protected or considered
or and it's just like I feel like that
would be exhausting it's weird I
couldn't live that way yeah of course
it's she's a I mean she's a machine and
she knows what she deserves and I think
it's weird because up until a week ago I
didn't understand this because I think
when I was first watching it I was kind
of like well because no one took me
seriously in these movies and I was just
I had to play the maid and I had to play
the this and this and you're kind of
like
oh well we loved that like we I think in
my not we love that you were denigrated
to a maid like it was like Julia Roberts
played a prostitute like it's just kind
of I didn't we all love you so much I
don't think I re we re like when we were
making fun of Julie
I think we were making fun of kind of
the movie and not you like we weren't we
didn't think it was your fault yeah like
she probably internalized all that but I
mean we know she did internalize that
criticism so much honestly Julie like
destroyed lives like what Martin breast
was like a very well respected director
it was also the where'd he go first time
that
you knew so much about someone's
personal life that once you saw them
acting it felt like bad acting because
you knew them too well so it was like
right this was like the first time the
internet world it's like like it was you
could see video ubiquitous of Ben
Affleck it's all we saw we were
inundates in indones by images of them
to the point to where now you want me to
go pay to see them but I see them for
free all day every day I have to say
though and I'm sure you've discussed
this to death at some point but I I I'm
so happy that Ben and JLo are back
together
like them getting they're not discussed
at once so I'm getting married is such a
win for me personally
why is that I I when they got engaged
the first time I actually went to
Claire's and bought a replica of the
pink diamond engagement ring and I was
by the way not a child I was a adult
with a full-time job so you got tetanus
how did you survive that no I got I was
just like I I I loved them so much
together I love this I just think it is
like the hottest energy and like for
them to get back together was already
such a treat this will be fleeting no no
they took it all the way across the
finish line
they are married like I am it's like
it's like closure for me that is so
funny I wanted to do because I I don't
particularly like love podcasting it's
it's people love the show and I'm so
grateful I just don't think I'm like
that good at it and I think you're great
at it thank you I think it's like just
be authentic and if the people that fuck
with you fuck with you and they don't
don't like you know what I mean so it's
like um uh I wanted to do a segment that
was um
I don't think we talked enough about
this like there's things that happen in
the news uh 20 years ago before I had a
platform and before like I need to like
go back to uh Gwen and Brad because I
have thoughts like oh yeah we need to
recover yeah yeah it's like let's re
it's called Old news like I know this is
old news but I didn't we didn't analyze
this nearly enough yeah because we
didn't yeah but at the time we we didn't
have the platform exactly it oh my God
Gwyneth and Brad amazing like it's just
like I'm just fascinated by shit like
that by the way Gwyneth and Ben like
there's just a lot that like I we need
to like regroup on that's really
fascinating to me but yeah I remember
watching the documentary and kind of
being like I think you have the perfect
career so why are you you mad about your
career and then I went oh I'm expecting
you to not have feelings yeah because
you're so successful and I think you've
won and you don't how dare you not agree
with with my assessment of your career
like I couldn't process and so and then
this past week I had someone be so
shitty to me on social on Twitter I
don't go on Twitter I'm not like it's
just for someone runs it and someone
made this reaction video making fun of
me and that's fine plenty of people do
it uh and I'm so I know female comedians
are like truly the most hated species of
people it's like it's fascinating you
love us or you hate us and I know like
half of it has to do with me you know
what I mean half like or you know it
doesn't matter I've tried to quantify it
I don't know if it's always I I wouldn't
it's I I think most of the time it's
like 80
misogyny fair fair yeah men and women
I'm saying that's very um
self-effacing of you to claim 50 of the
blame because I wouldn't go that far but
I think maybe for like Maria Bamford
it's 80. for me it might be 50. I don't
like help the ball going the other
direction like I know I'm like here's a
hot take here I'm not married I don't
have kids like I know that I make it
easy you know what I mean and so uh what
I'm laughing because there's a document
on my computer somewhere where I
literally came up with a percentage of
how much hate I get that I thought I
actually deserved versus how much was so
so it's I didn't know anyone else had
done this I got it so bad right that I
don't I went numb and now I'm having
like so much fun and I don't when you
don't care people go even harder because
like well I need to be even rougher on
you for you to feel it right I can't
hurt you anymore so I have to go even
further you know so it's sort of like
you know it's fine but it's very rare
that anything hurts my feelings I'm
always like I I have accomplished all of
my goals I am so fucking grateful all
I've like worked my ass off I know I'm
good at stand up like I uh anything
after this is all icing on the cake like
if you hate me that means you've heard
of me if you hated my special that means
you watch my special like all I ever I
didn't I didn't you can't write on your
vision board and every I have to be
universally beloved yeah which is
impossible I get to make a living
telling jokes if it means that I get to
act and move I get to be on like if you
if you're mad at me on Twitter like
that's fair if it means I get to keep
doing this you know what I mean so it's
a fair price to pay 100 and this also I
really push back on this thing because
the comedians you're like we're fighting
for the First Amendment and Free Speech
unless you don't like me in which case
you don't get to have free speech yeah
you don't get to say you don't think I'm
funny that's where the First Amendment
stops like it's just so like and so um
and I know we're triggering like we're
true
it's like like people have a right to
say whatever they want about me and also
right but what comedians do is we go did
you like that and they go no and we're
like What if that's not how it works
like we go you know we trust an audience
if they're not laughing at us we go I'm
gonna change that joke but if they say I
didn't think that was funny you're like
how dare you you're only allowed to do
that in a club in front of me in the
dark and that I'll believe you I'll
believe you when you're drunk but now
when you're sober right when you're
drunk you know the truth it's like it's
just such a backwards sort of thing I
know I I've even had people say to me
you know when I've talked about a
disappointment I had in my career or
something that really hurt me and
they're just like oh I don't even
remember that I'm like but it was the
biggest thing that ever happened because
it was to me you know what I mean it was
like in my life this thing that happened
was a seismic event for you like you're
just like oh Brooke's doing well for
herself like so it's crazy when you when
you state it that way like it never
occurred to me because it makes me like
I I'm obsessed with the idea of everyone
like Jennifer's Body is the best movie
ever made it's iconic like when people
say that to you or you like like you're
bringing what like there's just
something of I feel like I walk through
the shit on that and now you love it I
always feel a little suspicious when
people are like I got so much shit first
it's like when people come up to me and
they're like this is very different
obviously I've been people like I'm
obsessed with your sitcom I'm like are
you mocking me don't mock me like I'm
like no I know exactly what it took me a
while to get comfortable with the
bodisance with some people liking
Jennifer's Body all of a sudden yeah but
where were you five years ago when I
needed you that was initially my take
where I was like well I would have liked
to have been a theatrical hit you know
that would have been really great for me
especially at that time in my life but I
don't need you to like announce at the
same time a lot of the people that are
into it now we're too young to see it at
the time so it's not their fault like
they're people born yet they were cool
enough just weren't old enough they were
not old enough or born so yeah because
many of the people who have embraced
that movie are are gen Z so do you feel
like you have a little bit of a
Detachment now of like I'm putting this
out to my point about the Billboards and
there's I don't think movies should be
judged on their first weekend you know I
hate that and I don't think that TV
shows should be judged when they're you
know the ratings they get their first
episode I mean it's like I think it
should be like back in the day where
they would give a Seinfeld like two
seasons to breathe before they decided
to cancel it you know first episode's
always the worst episode yeah that's the
thing except cheers so yeah I like that
that was the exception yeah but that's
uh yeah I in general I hate this idea of
like
you know we used to have like sleeper
hits you had movies that grew an
audience and now it's like yeah first
weekend didn't work dump it I know you
want to do have done TV by the way you
know that I um want to start a channel
maybe I'll talk to Kiki Palmer about it
she just started a network
um that's all just old pilots so it's
just I'd watch that in uh it's just
Pilots that have never heard there is a
gold mine of incredible shows oh I've
made at least two or three that have
never done Pilots that have never aired
and they're who's in them
like you know what interesting people
yeah there's a pilot I did with Ben
Stiller Dave and Wayne directed it oh
this is like wow it's me John Goodman uh
Jordan peel has uh is the receptionist
wow it has four lines like even the
number seven on the call sheet are like
Legends you're like how just air it air
it my friend my my wonderful friend
Laureen scafaria made a pilot with Kate
Berlin John early that is like one of
the best things I've ever seen in my
life and it never aired to make the show
you're right it could go to the channel
yeah just buy it back and put it on the
channel or the channel should just buy
them all back so I'm like kind of like
trying to figure out how you know to do
it it's not that hard it's just no one's
thought no one has time to think about
like everyone's like what's the next
thing what's the next thing instead of
going wait what do we already have that
would be amazing because it's just like
the problem is I mean then people are
like but we you know you're it every
every installment leaves you wanting
more and more will never come
you know what content that leaves people
wanting more I would like more of that
yeah as opposed to a question most
things I'm like I'd like less of this
yeah I don't need eight parts of this
docu-series but all the way also I'm not
it's not my job to manage the dopamine
receptors you have to leave yes okay go
I'm leaving I'm sorry okay last thing
okay oh God ah red flags and people what
did you learn about uh human nature over
your life uh from uh everything from
when you started dancing in gentlemen's
clubs and blogging about it and writing
a book directing a movie writing a movie
what have you learned about human nature
that you wish you knew earlier
oh my goodness
whoa this is such a great question
um
I
I have always been a very um
trusting person
I still am I would still describe myself
as gullible
um and you know obviously I've I have
had to to learn to be a bit more
Discerning would you want to be just uh
living always assuming someone's lying
well this thing is I like Taylor Swift
as a good quote about this where you
know people say oh have you become more
thick-skinned after all the criticism
and you know whatever that you've
endured and she's like I don't want to
have thick skin because I'm an artist
like I need to be sensitive I need to be
sensitive too so I also have remained
thin-skinned I would rather be the
gullible one that gets their heart
broken every now and then or is like oh
that wasn't true I can handle someone
lying I know I know what that is and
then in terms of uh
stripping you know what's so interesting
is like
the same dudes that would have like hit
on me relentlessly in public wouldn't
get a dance for me in the club because
it I in a strip club you are selling
the illusion that you have no Humanity
that you are like like you can't have a
chip in your nail polish like these guys
don't want to be reminded of your
Humanity they want to be entertained by
almost like this hologram of a woman and
someone who's enjoying doing the thing
that they need them to do with no
feelings yeah and it was always I always
wondered like
I don't know was just like the whole
construction of femininity in the strip
club was always so fascinating to
observe and it was never like a great
fit for me because first of all I mean
I'm like neither that hot or that
persuasive but like you need to be like
a Salesman but thank you but like I I
think you're one of the prettiest people
I've ever seen that's very you're very
sweet but I think that um
you also I'm sorry
like I'm just gonna say it and we can
cut it out uh
your body is so amazing oh my God thank
you I I certainly have a lot of people
talk about it a lot who's a lot of
people oh I mean it pretty much every
time you come up in a conversation
you're like and she's stunning and she
has
I ate the tushy that I would pay for
this one's new this is new I thank you
very much and you know what you are like
Betty Page like Dina Von Teese like hot
I did not grow up in an era where my
body type was agree popular so I can
tell I was mocked for that the idea the
body idea was uh Kate Moss sits on a
stick or okay yes basically so Pamela or
Kate passing away right and so suddenly
and this was funny this actually
the the young people some of the young
people in the cast of Jagged Little Pill
when we were putting it up would would
tell me that I had a they would comment
on my body in a complimentary way and I
would always be like and these are like
young kids and I was like oh you guys
just have a totally different thing
you're into and by the way I don't think
Kim Kardashian I think we owe her a lot
for that oh Kim for sure I know we're
mad at Kim for a lot of reasons I get it
finally no 100 I know this do you
remember the discourse around JLo it was
crazy
it was like her she wore a dress yeah
yeah
and showing her butt yeah and it was
just BBL City out there everyone's out
there getting their their big their big
booties yeah we have to a lot to think
in terms of JLo and Kim well thank you
very much that's the greatest problem
last thing I'm gonna say red flags about
people when you're hiring people when
you're dating people when you're
deciding to work with someone
it can be as simple as as a text while
they're talking to you or
when I'm working in like a writer's room
for instance like I really need to be
surrounded by garbage like I need to eat
crap yeah I bought candy in the writer's
room and the people that I've worked
with who were like I'm you know like
they want like plain almonds in the
writer's room I have found that it's
often not a fit
I know that's bad because you're because
you know why you literally have bad
taste no I'm just like if you CA if you
don't eat food like that's kind of a red
flag for me I'm sorry yeah obviously I'm
not shaming anyone with a disordered
eating situation or whatever but like I
I need to be able to like break bread
with you and by Bread I mean like bread
focaccia
like cheesy hot Focaccia but because
it's
because it's you're into hurting
yourself and that's fine
yeah that's fine you know what I mean
but it might just not be a match I mean
Ninja I'm so self-destructive like I
would chain smoke in a writer's room if
I could but we're just not legally
allowed to right like I would have a
like I would chain smoke through a donut
like blowing the smoke out the hole of
an iced sprinkled donut is how I would
be living my life if you know that were
allowed so yeah the the there's a lot of
wealth like I do have sliced almonds on
my funnel cake yeah
but like I you know yeah that's kind of
I have to admit I have discriminated
against against applicants who uh seemed
like
you don't get to be on a cleanse at work
we don't all have to accommodate your
low blood sugar and constantly going to
shit it's like I'm gonna cleanse I'm one
of this I'm sipping bone broth while
we're breaking the story no that's for
your off time yeah you know what I mean
like that you can't I sorry I just I'm
this and I I'm just like really tired
because I have no blood sugar because I
only drink cayenne pepper and like
fucking whatever it's like okay do it
when on a week off you don't get to do
that here like I'm an asshole if I fine
I'm an asshole but like
your food should not be your dietary
shit I shouldn't be thinking about it
yeah I shouldn't we shouldn't all have
to take on that I mean I'm also I'm on
the other side of the spectrum though
where it's just distractingly bad
I don't know like I I had candy corn for
breakfast
you're the only other person I've met my
favorite candy it's so good everyone
it's huge everybody holds one pound not
even one pound like I like I have like a
like a preemie sized like an infant
sized bag of candy corn in my fridge
right now candy corn more like most
people eat corn yes exactly it is corn
that's my corn although I did just have
the milk cornbread cookie and it's well
those are so good oh my God all those
milk cookies oh my God yeah it's just
like a little mini birthday cake to go
okay I'm letting you go I
just love you and I love you this is the
like honestly the best time I've ever
had on a podcast come on so much the
bars the bars the bar is not though the
bar is is Sky High you know I've I've
sat with many a luminary but this has
been just an absolutely delightful
experience and I'm I'm so appreciative
thank you and um uh next time you have
something coming out I'm gonna force you
to come back I will I will guilt you I
will shame are you kidding Etc I'm not
leaving
I'm just going down the hall to my room
I'm sad that's right I'm moving her into
the horse room in the house you guys
yeah I mean I'd love to be here this is
this house is amazing uh invite your
sons over uh come and have them destroy
everything people say that and they
don't know what they're getting into I
kind of do because I don't have kids I
don't have the delusion that they're
Angels right I got it I see what you're
doing what I'm saying I just see them
you know how bad they are because
I never see the good side it's great but
I actually love that do you um I know
you work with Lucy k a while ago forget
about whatever reason stuff but he did
have um did you ever see that bit he did
about the difference between boys and
girls no so having boys they'll boys
will destroy your stuff the girls will
destroy you psychologically and you know
what I think that's true and he said he
was like I was with one of my because he
has two girls they were different this
is when they were like five and seven or
something and uh the oh and uh Barbie
um the five-year-olds Barbie had uh she
like ripped off and she couldn't get it
back on and she said well my Barbie had
ripped off so you know my sister's
Barbie's head isn't ripped off so I need
you to rip it off so it's fair
and he went and I did it
he was ripping off a Barbie head it's
just like psychologically he's like this
is the most fucked up place I've ever
been to yeah I know that's messed up
yeah that's messed up and my sons really
are have been they've destroyed a lot of
property but they are like
other than that you know they're a lot
of fun I cannot wait to meet Sons raised
by you well you know there I have to
admit the vision that I had for what
kind of sons I might have didn't
entirely play out like I was of course
thinking like
super into fashion like purses
um you know just wanted to watch into
the woods with me all the time that
didn't happen they were but everything
skips it this was my sorry this was the
only sorry really quick just because you
made a movie obviously that had uh
abortion themes everyone's fighting
about blondes
um I'm kind of glad we didn't get to it
because it's it's it's a lot to unpack
but I was trying to defend someone that
wanted people to have abortions and I
I'll just record it and show it to you
because this is where I got to I was
like okay I'm gonna figure out a way to
defend this like I just as a thought
exercise my dad always said in order to
have an opinion if you can't defend the
other opinion yours is bullshit so if
you can't find a way you know and so
like and I was just like Debate Club is
like my favorite show and um and I was
like okay here's what it is there is
science so much on how uh I was on I was
with this is I'm just gonna say who it
was I know this didn't sound douchey I
was with Mark Wahlberg and his wife and
his wife who is amazing she's like Gore
she has the Chanel person she's like and
you're like like oh my God this would be
it would be my dream to have you as my
mom like I didn't go through your closet
I could borrow your purses and her
teenage daughter is like Chanel gross
like why would you wear Louis Vuitton
like is like anti because there's a
biological basis for why Offspring want
to differentiate from their mothers it's
due to her Predators so you it's like
the same way that that um uh animal uh
wolves inside they eat their placenta
not because it's good for them it's
because the scent of blood will draw
Predator so they just eat it to get rid
of it you know so there is a biological
basis for Offspring having to be as
different as possible as their primary
caretaker definitely happen so it's like
whatever you are they're just gonna be
the opposite it's not personal this is
how they're wired to be I need to be as
different as you as possible because
predators are coming for you because
you're old and I need them to not see me
as you know you and um and so I was like
okay so if you're a pro-life person
forced birth person
you can go I fucking hate liberals so
I'm gonna make them have kids because
then their kids will backlash against
them and become conservatives oh yeah
because I was like you know that if you
make liberals have kids you're just
making more liberals
but the science would be that
necessarily it's true you know what I
mean so I was I was like that's how far
down the rabbit hole I went
I'm trying to understand that why you'd
want to force women to have children
they don't want like I was just like how
could I possibly get there
I love you on that note let's abort this
interview okay we believe an abortion
here at the show
your body your choice and she's choicing
to get the fuck out of here I love you
guys don't ride elephants
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]